[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis
j'espère que vous avez été sages l'ont
été patron j'en suis certain mais ses
cornichons qui me donne bien du souci il
dort n'importe où pourvu qu'il n'est pas
couché à l'appel et toi courage north
descend vite - le jeune
papa
d'ivoire corniche ah oui
et puis des bûches
[Musique]
ça va être formidable
presque comme dans la forêt bonsoir les
enfants
salut
volontiers au travail longs musique
au choc la rue du rosier d'accord je
connais pas je vous écoute comme ça tu
pourra la prendre
plus voilà la
mongie à quatre fers au velours
aussi à quatre fleurs d'une chambre
haute en couleurs quant à lui est arrivé
bon je peux le rouge encore elle y est
d'arriver meilleure affaire monde avait
[Musique]
fini 4e commission non 4 champignons
nous notre boutures ont
nettement et les haies messieurs le
bouton de rose dans ce tous les cadres
entre eux taïg autres merveilleux quand
le soleil est levé
motorola
en fusionner dans l'art osé porter le
voile à bord bouger pour le retour le
journal
[Musique]
merci maman tu nous as beau
j'aimerais quand même savoir ce que vous
préparez vous rien dire c'est une
surprise de voir
une fête qui verra vous êtes gentils les
petits mais ne fait pas de bêtise et toi
corniche on retrouve des souliers
t'inquiète pas mon gros nounours allons
nicolaï pas preneur oui il est à
[Musique]
c'est une belle surprise comme près par
la dass c'est très gentil suis sûr que
ça plaira là j'ai pas lu ne
demain
cornichons tué dans la salle de bain non
j'ai près de la cheminée
surveille le bois pour koné sipa bonne
nuit mon petit corniche aux salles une
ourse
fait beau rêve
[Musique]
pas trop il me prépare une nouvelle
surprise le cher petit j'ai hâte d'être
à demain en route mon bon nounours allez
vite vous coucher les enfants n'oubliez
pas de faire votre toilette de bien vous
laver les dents est fait pour
[Musique]